berges frist irgendwelche bremse ich bin
aber aber aber aber aber altern ein
wenig auf die bremse
ich steckte mal wieder bei die hinten
drin mal wieder so richtig geile karren
fahren smarte hier links stehen aber
richtig geile kann in diesem dieser
einfluss ja so im singleplayer das
multiplayer ähnliche nicht
wiedergutgemacht status können wir jetzt
tanken sticker so ich bin ein bisschen
aufgeregt
in ravenna aufregt die werfen könnte
noch keine karten seien auf jeden fall
nicht weg
ich hab' ich fahre gerade aus ja vorhin
links 3 ich fahre jetzt geradeaus
ich habe ja ein bisschen starken konnte
die kammer von vorne liegt reifen an
vor allem aber so ok hopsten
wie kann es sein dass pc auto schneller
sind als wir
dieses liegt noch riesige die türme auf
entziehen
die hat bisher auch wer ist unsichtbaren
streckt
okay da sind cocker mich schießen und
ich kam einfach nicht als zwei koffer
mit dem mit dem man nicht mit unserer
schrottkarre ganz dieser art kilometern
sind nur noch fünf mit mit mir mit
meinem links 3 kann ich richtig gut so
um kurve fahren wir dürfen jetzt auch
noch keine karte clown weil die bullen
der direkt hinter anwenden wenn ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein
er wolle man sich doch eine andere karte
holen man ja ja ja aber das deuten
kilometer ja aber das ist ja nicht mehr
viel sind wir auch relativ schnell dafür
dass du endlich sonst so er beim joggen
gesehen wie eine dame einfach jedes auto
aber irgendwie das auto kriegt weniger
kratzer aus als dein biz mobil
der guckt immer die gala vom vorjahr
kommt ein bisschen die kleine nicht
einfach so die kurve muss mit der mann
wollte und ihm mut und die teilnehmer
auf aber ansonsten halte die tür ist
einfach ein bisschen was ich mir mit
eingekauft habe einfach ein geiler
bietet als stelle von tiefer gelegt ist
jetzt mit geöffneter tür nach klagen die
büsche habe ich gerade so gebremst den
autos wir sind noch in zwei kilometern
wenn man jetzt sehen wir auch eine lukas
abkürzung
doch ich habe richtig keine abkürzung
ist es ist es noch 1 ich glaube du hast
du den wegpunkt gesetzt und wir beide
kennen sich 21 kilometer wir können
eigentlich eine abkürzung fahren der
castelberg muss man immer darum fahren
obwohl es luftlinie 20 meter oder so
wären wenn ich eigentlich in deine
aufnahme die ganze laut würde ich mein
headset noch an du bist bei mir mega
rauschen aber dass das solltest du hast
du es im spiel mal zu ja ja ja du ich
habe mich am anfang gar nicht mit einer
mentorin ausgemacht ist ganz gut dass
dies den trotzdem aufnimmt ja die frage
ist ob jetzt gatow mäßig ja deswegen das
nimmt allianz hält er aber nimmt es auch
meinem eingeladenen spieler aber das
müsste ja eigentlich relativ synchronen
sein ich denke unsere stimmen wenn die
leute seien
und wenn es so war dann tut uns leid wir
werden es in den nächsten folgen
verbessern
ich wäre auch dafür dass jetzt noch 20
minuten aufnehmen
was ist da gut eingepackt in panik wenn
du vorne einsteigen wo ich erstmal aus
ich denke tochter 13
ich glaube auf den letzten metern fahren
wegen welche bergsteiger um kommen die
bullen da muss ich da hinkommen
diesmal ist es wieder nein das muss
bear grylls frist irgendwelche fremd
aber aber aber aber aber eltern einfach
ich kann aber egal was bei kilometer 17
kilometer jetzt nur noch drei buden ich
habe mir dieses takt wir müssen jetzt
gemeinsam schaffen
dieses taxi ist kult ist dass das taxi
der freundschaft und bin ich da nicht
ein stück wir noch einmal an alle reifen
alle türen sind breiter als lang hat
mich oben die wird auch verlassen
alle glauben schenkt vor uns nicht all
das ist ein machtwort musst du bist
gerade bei mir
wir sind voll durch den stein gletscher
hochgesprungen
aber ich glaube es wird bei mir lacht
ich bin der falsche weg
guck dir das macht der garden alter
denkmuster ist hier längst linkshänder
links rein sind sind rappelvoll
egal aber wir haben die bullen zu melden
ich konnte mich etwa 800 meter muss mir
so ein bisschen lotsen so viele wie kein
schneiden rechts man keinen weg echt
nicht ausmachen ich muss auf dem weg
bleiben ich darf nicht über die natur
fahren hätte nicht bitte auch keine
coolen look als abkürzung ich fand ich
stark ist hat den regalen verkauf das
war doch nichts passiert das leibnitzer
grids abkürzung steht man da oben stehen
und einfach runtergeflogen oder eher
gefallen
warum steht da oben dass das verleitet
ein doch richtig dazu dann einfach
gleich mal den berg runter zu fahren
ich werde auf die wicklung falsch
gesetzter steht hier nicht
diese befänden jetzt echt dein auto
steht nämlich um einen ganzen eimer aber
ich ja was zuletzt ein crash
aber ich finde es trotzdem hier war die
stelle wo ich kann nicht so einsteigen
alter hatte das mich mehr
ach man kann nur von ihr erwarte du
fährst trotzdem jetzt kam raus dass wir
sie nicht fahren
ich kann nicht fahren
doch du kannst wirklich nicht fahren
aber ich glaube geworden
du hast auch bock auf sterben ich habe
richtig bock auf das spiel
kratzer lineare schon wissen kann
es ist so ich habe eine tür gibt die
mittelmotor nicht einfach keinen motor
aber ich finde es schon cool so ohne
türen dass das könnte echt ne geile
aktion seine brille sandisk ist meine
ganz einfach gleich im gleichgewicht in
welchem us customs ohne mutter habe und
auf jeden fall mit der japaner [ __ ]
dabei bestimmt die müssen wir noch oben
augen um aufbauend auf diesem morgen
aber nie wettkämpfe
du kannst nicht fahren nein nein ich
jetzt wasser nicht dass das wird nicht
ins wasser gehen
das ist eine richtig geile ausweg da
fährt die bahn her
man habe eine meinung ja das ist jetzt
nicht der strand ganz unten strand
sondern einfach nur dass sand und meer
ich würde mich umbringen wenn ich hier
autofahrer sein müsste du willst du
wirklich zu das budget aber egal
das macht macht man das nächste land
werden
jetzt kann ich aber gut gefahren ich
hasse stein ins rollen gebracht
er wollte den berg und tag warte ich
mache den berg runter wenn du machst
gerade dass wir den berg runter wollen
also in die falsche richtung
aber ich will ja nicht normal lang
fahren ich weiß dass man den berg
gerühmt wird
nein aber ich kann noch zu ersetzen
weißt du was einfach für mensch bin der
mensch gerne
ich will so das kotzen wenn ich der
hipster wurde jetzt erwarte ich fahre
hier außenbahn druck der weg sogar viel
schneller alte ich spürte da
redaktionssystem vor allem die das auto
aber immer noch so heftig ich bin
alarmiert weil ich kurz das ist ihm wohl
wieder haben die sterne wenn man den
ball vorbei beamten weil ich eventuell
daneben geschossen aber auch nur einmal
geschafft noch nicht mal getroffen aber
sei noch nicht nur aus vielen familien
oder denke einfach wenn er ihn was auf
fahrrädern ist es mir lange ich muss die
botanik genießen
ich fand wir müssen irgendwie
fördermenge wie soll mit zwei statt nur
das
die bullen dann kriegen die oberfläche
kommen
heute muss ich habe das parlament wieder
leben
möchtet ihr leben mein ganzes leben
direkt hinter dem berg richtig schön
lang mein gott oh mein gott ich war
mutig macht abkürzung
die abkürzung stark
wir verstecken uns in unserem auto in
dem wir gesucht sind haben die duale
ausbildung übernehmen
ich habe irgendwann weiß ich nicht ja ja
wir haben es geschafft
du bist auch direkt die stelle ist weg
doch jetzt wirtschaft nach hause kommt
ohne dafür zehn milliarden sterne haben
wisse ja ich werde nichts mehr schießen
nicht vertun und mittelfinger
nein falsch ist das wieder geschossen
denn er war wohl in berlin machten dann
übrigens kind das könnt ihr euch auch zu
hause mal vorn wir können einfach
schießen wenn keine andere ist
vollkommen nicht sagte gerade richtig
schön mittelfinger
wir haben so dass er selber aus
ich bin auch als zehnter nur der teil
der defcon aber wenn ich das macht
unsere alter ist da hinten jetzt
wirklich dieses meetings